[Music]
the suit doesn't make a man
that's what's inside the suit that
counts
it's resourcefulness
and perhaps an open heart
I haven't finished my drink
this sacred Institution
power beyond your imagination
Winston your brother stole something
from me
dangerous people
find him because if you don't I'll bring
the weight of this whole institution
down on you both
Sharon
show our guests the door
we may have a mistake coming here you're
my brother Frankie we have to strike
first
and I need all the help I can get how
are we supposed to believe a guy in an
ascot can pull this off
we're going to take on the Continental
every freak in that hotel will be asked
well that's lovely
we need guns
lots of guns
[Music]
this is more than Vengeance this is
justice
[Music]
can you dig it
let's take this house
and everything that comes with it
and away we go
[Music]
foreign